my report here as a warning has some
flash photography
gilan maxwell traveled on private planes
between mansions on sprawling estates
but inside these homes she and jeffrey
epstein orchestrated a sex trafficking
operation
teenagers from fractured families
singled out for sexual abuse and brought
here they are now grown women who
brought down guillen maxwell annie
farmer is one of them she was abused by
maxwell when she was 16. i
wasn't sure that this day would ever
come and
i just feel so grateful that the jury
believed us and sent a strong message
that perpetrators of sexual abuse and
exploitation will be held accountable no
matter how much power and privilege that
they have it wasn't just the four women
testifying in this case whose lives were
devastated many more like sarah ransom
were waiting hoping for this verdict
what was it that gillane did
to
manipulate girls in order to serve them
up to jeffrey epstein what was her role
in the crime so gilean was the main
enforcer she was um you know even before
i met elaine
jeffrey said you answer to gilean you
know
she is the lady of the house she is
um you just don't cross her she forced
me into jeffrey's room to be raped
and then when i walked out
well walked limped i mean whatever you
do when you've just been been brutally
raped
i looked at her
and that's why it was really important
for me to be there
and look at her because when i looked at
her
after she forced me into the room to be
raped
she smiled
and that's why i had to be there because
you know what
i smiled right at back right back at her
and i saw her
this former federal prosecutor believes
maxwell will spend the rest of her life
in prison unless she can cut a deal
is there any chance that gulen maxwell's
sentence could be commuted if she were
to blow the whistle for example on
co-conspirators
there certainly is a process where
individuals can cooperate after
conviction
and get you know credit for that
cooperation
in this case i haven't seen any
indication that that's going to happen i
do think
she would have to bring some incredibly
valuable information to the table for
the government to want to meet with her
virginia du frey didn't take the stand
but loomed large over this case she says
she was trafficked around the world and
forced to have sex with famous men
including prince andrew claims he denies
we
were told constantly you know these
people will never go to jail they
they're too powerful they're too rich
and
we live in a new day and it just goes to
show that
you know um
this is not the end this is just the
beginning they were partners in crime
two sexual predators but survivors
believe there were more involved in this
scheme for whom justice is also long
overdue
in the last couple of minutes i've just
spoken to leah saffin who's a personal
lawyer for glenn maxwell she was in
court every day of the trial sat in the
front row of that court just behind
glenn maxwell regularly speaking with
her during breaks in testimony leah came
out of the building behind me she said
she'd not been allowed to see gulen this
evening but she did reaffirm that the
the family that guillen is appealing
this verdict she also said that glenn
maxwell is being subjected to cruel and
unusual punishments in the building
behind me she said that the light in her
cell is being left on permanently which
is stopping her sleeping it's a
complaint that the family have mentioned
before
but certainly these five guilty verdicts
against gulen maxwell are not the end of
the story she also faces two outstanding
perjury charges for which she may still
face trial it could be though that
federal prosecutors opt to drop those
two perjury charges because they've been
so successful in this initial
prosecution and because most probably
gillen maxwell will already be spending
the rest of her life behind bars